this chapter mr. baseball the story of
Connie Mack it was a day in 1949 Connie
Mack was being honored for his lifetime of
service to baseball to him the applause of
the fans was as familiar as their cat calls
in his long eventful career yet heard both
often born during the civil war Connie Mack
began playing baseball when army fort still
guarded the western frontier against raiding
Indians by 1886 when folks still wrote in
buggies and horse cars he was a professional
ballplayer catcher for the Washington Senators
1894 gentleman Jim Corbett was fighting George
Courtenay by then Connie Mack was manager of the
Pittsburgh Pirates he went on to become manager
and part owner of the Philadelphia Athletics
in nineteen two when the Wright brothers were
solving the problems of flight Connie Mack
won his first pennant it caused far more
excitement than the first plane flight in
history then in 1910 what Connie macit
was a crucial pennant and World Series
he had gone deep into debt to build a new
baseball stadium to keep the seats filled
with paying fans he needed a championship team
Mac had done his best his pitching star was the
great chief bender another fine pitcher
Jack Coombs Jack berry played shortstop
any Collinsworth at second and home run Baker at
third although underdogs in that World Series the
A's trounced the Cubs Connie had his first World
Championship the Philadelphia fans went wild
next year cheered by the fans Connie led the
A's to another pennant in the World Series of
1911 his opponents were John J McGraw and the
New York Giants Connie's men won he repeated
the victor in 1913 again beating McGraw and
the Giants that made Connie Mack the first
manager and baseball to win three World Series
the future looked good you were happily married
and ranked with the greatest managers of all
time but a year later it was all swept away
a rival league tempted your players with
large salaries facing financial ruin you
sold your stars it was that or bankruptcy Eddie
Collins went first sold to the Chicago White Sox
Jack berry so to the Boston Red Sox home
run Baker sold to the Yankees you're
famous infield gone the A's plunged
to the bottom of the American League
with the Athletics in last place empty seats at
the stadium the fans called you a team wrecker you
didn't argue quietly you began to rebuild in the
process you made mistakes a rookie pitcher named
Babe Ruth was offered for sale cheap you were
short of cash and turned him down instead you
searched the sandlots for youngsters to develop
you found one in peppery infielder Jimmy dykes
but in 1920 down south for spring training you
decided that way was too slow you would buy the
players who could make the Athletics of pennant
contender even if it meant going into debt year
by year new stars were added to the rosters the
best pitchers you could buy the best catcher the
most powerful hitters in 1927 the greatest star
of them all joined your club the immortal Ty Cobb
table salaries 70,000 a year but he was worth it
now after 13 lean years you were ready to make a
bid for the American League pennant the season
of 1927 began you soon learned it would not be
a year of victory you were competing against an
invincible team the New York Yankees with Babe
Ruth lashing out 60 home runs and all-time record
the Yankees finished first they looked capable of
continuing their record-breaking pace in
definitely had the huge sums spent early
build the Athletics been wasted it was ironic to
recall that Babe Ruth could have been on your team
you are now 65 years old it seemed that for your
remaining years in baseball the Yankees would
always stand between you and the pennant Connie
Mack had been discouraged in 1927 but two years
later the Athletics faced the Chicago Cubs in
the World Series pitching ace lefty Grove had
won 20 games the batting lineup contained great
sluggers Bing Miller Mickey Cochrane Al Simmons
Jimmy Fox with Grove on the pitching staff were
Quinn Wahlberg Rommel and Earnshaw an outstanding
team the first game of the series was played
before President Herbert Hoover there was one big
question as Mac and Chicago manager Joe McCarthy
shook hands who would be Connie's starting pitcher
he chose Howard empty a has-been the fans were
amazed but empty struck out 13 Chicago hitters
a new world series record the Athletics won the
first game with ease and went on to capture the
series after 16 years the World Championship
the applause was sweet just honey Philadelphia
expected another world championship in 1930 and
the city was not disappointed but in 1931 it was a
different story in the World Series that year the
Athletics faced the st. Louis Cardinals connie's
men were favored to win but on the Cardinal team
was a lad named pepper Martin the sports riders
had nicknamed him the wild horse of the osage
living up to his nickname pepper Martin ran wild
in that World Series the A's pitching aces Grove
and earnshaw were helpless against him Martin hit
almost at will ran the bases like a madman and
was flawless in the field the Athletics fought
back tied the series they could still win but
in the last game sparked by Martin's hitting
and fielding the Cardinals triumph it had taken
Connie Mack 13 years to return to the top of the
heap that World Series defeat was the beginning of
his slide back to the bottom Connie went back to
Philadelphia and troubles a depression gripped
the country unemployed men sold apples in the
streets money was scarce and Connie couldn't
meet his high salaried payroll sorrowfully he
broke up his greatest team el Simmons his great
Slugger was sold in fielded Jimmy dykes was sold
pitching stars left a Grove in George Earnshaw
sold you Star catcher Mickey Cochrane sold
jimmie foxx one of the greatest sluggers
of all sold they had to go one bright spot
in the picture with Babe Ruth you sail to
Japan in 1934 leading a team of American
League stars to play against the Nipponese you
received a royal welcome the Japanese rightly
regarded you and Ruth as Giants of the game the
Bambino demonstrated his batting form he missed
the first ball then slammed one of his mighty
homers but it was only a pleasant interview
1937 President Roosevelt tossed out the first ball
to start the new season he was 74 years old at the
time come to quit not yet you wanted to win one
more penny spring training 1939 still pursuing
that last pennant could you fashion a pennant
winning team out of these players you tried hard
but didn't succeed during that season you were
taken seriously ill in Boston back to Philadelphia
and the hospital was this the end was the grand
old man of baseball through yet looked that way
but you recovered the years rolled by now it was
1946 in spring training Newcombe the newcomers for
material 2 flipped into a championship combination
but it was the same old story no sluggers like
Fox and Simmons no pitchers like lefty Grove you
showed the rookies how to handle the ball but you
knew before the season began that there would be
no pennant this year nineteen fifty you face the
inevitable 88 years old you gave up managership of
the Athletics to an old-time star Jimmy dykes you
couldn't have that last pennant but you could look
back on a lifetime of unequaled accomplishment in
baseball you had received many honors your wife
had reason to be proud from Judge Landers to
president will Herod the leaders of baseball had
proclaimed you their peer your old friend George
M Cohen had written the popular song in your
praise you were Philadelphia's outstanding citizen
your work had received international recognition
in 1949 the United Nations named
you as sports father of the year
who you had come the highest honor the national
pastime can bestow a place in baseball's Hall of
Fame there on a plaque listing the Immortals
of the game is the name of Connie Mack place
there in recognition of your half-century
of leadership although you had never won
that last pennant you received something
far more precious the title mr. baseball